We are here with my dear friend, naturalist,
and lifestyle expert, Danny Seo,
and, boy, does he have the goods.
Danny Seo, you have changed my life yet again.
What are we doing this time?
Okay, so if you can't save that sweater
'cause it's far too gone,
or maybe it's like a cashmere sweater
or a very nice, soft, cozy, expensive sweater,
you don't want to donate it quite yet,
we're gonna reupholster a chair
and make cozy sweater chairs.
Oh, my God, that's so cute!
Like, how cute is that?
So, like-
I've never seen that before.
Yes, like, imagine just sitting on cashmere.
This is the world's easiest craft project,
so I'm inspired by, like,
let's imagine it's a mix of MacGyver
and Drew Barrymore, okay?
Aargh!
I love that combination!
Crafty, resourceful.
So, you pop off the the seat cushion from a chair.
So, this is pretty easy to do, there's little screws
on the bottom that you just pop out,
and you have this, like, empty cushion right here.
You rip off the old fabric,
and what we're gonna do is that you cut the sweater.
You want a big, flat piece,
so do you see what we've done here?
Just a nice, big, flat piece,
and then we're gonna take our seat cushion,
the cushion side all the way up.
You wrap it on top,
and this is where you wanna kinda like, you know,
make sure you get the pattern right.
If it's like an argyle or a zigzag or stripes,
that's where you have to just really kind of look at it,
but we love a solid because you can't screw up. (laughs)
So they say.
And then we're gonna flip it over, just like this,
and what's kinda nice is it already has, like,
existing staples in place, so you can use that as a guide.
And what I just do, Drew-
(loud bang)
(audience laughing)
(Danny laughs)
(Drew grunts)
And then you just staple.
Go like this, and then I do one in the middle here,
I go one in the middle here,
and then you go all the way around,
and then you're kind of just stretching it
to make sure it's tight and taut,
the same way that a professional would do this.
We go all the way here,
we can do this, and you just go around
and around and around.
Danny,
when you, like, wrap a gift,
is it like this?
Well, I don't use
a staple gun.
Really?
(laughing) No.
(audience laughing)
But, like,
our mutual friend, Martha Stewart, came on the show
and she taught me how to wrap a gift,
and it changed my life.
Did you just say, "mutual friend, Martha Stewart"?
Don't, don't you know her?
(audience laughing)
I don't know her.
Really?
(audience laughing loudly)
Well, in my fantasies-
But, like, now I'm like,
why, what, what did she say? (laughs)
It's so funny, I feel like in my fantasy,
we're all hanging out.
Is it?
I'm telling you, I have this fantasy.
We need to make it happen.
I am gonna have an ambulance nearby
'cause I will be having an aneurysm
(laughing) during the whole time.
Okay, so you staple all the way around,
you trim the excess, and then look at this, guys.
It's a signature.
I don't know what that is.
(audience applauding and cheering)
That's really good, so you can see, guys,
we have a blue one here,
or you have this beautiful, like,
more of a ski lodge, the pink ones.
I love the pink.
Look how cute that is,
and you could literally do-
Put this over there.
(audience cheering)
You could literally do-
(audience applauding)
We just need a third seat for our mutual friend,
Martha Stewart.
By the way, Martha,
come join Danny and I!
Danny wanted to help everyone get started
on their cleaning journey,
so he is kindly giving everyone in our audience a $100
Skout's Honor gift card.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Well, it's the world's best cleaning products.
I love them.
And they are,
according to Danny,
some of the world's best cleaning products,
and if there's anyone I trust on this planet
to take care of our planet,
it is you, Danny.
Aw!
And think about all the things you are doing.
I mean, you are really at the forefront
of a movement that not only we all need to get on,
but, like, you are way ahead of the curve,
and you are such a success story,
and we're all literally gonna live better lives for it.
Oh, thank you, Drew.
It's true, Danny.
I love you.
Congratulations again.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, everybody.
Go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com for instructions
on the cleaning solutions
and the reupholstering of the chairs and all things Danny.
(upbeat music)